c'est la bêtise humaine quand un humain
pêche un poisson c'est seulement 50% du
poisson qui est consommé je me trouve
dans un atelier de filetage sur le port
de Lorient c'est ici qu'on coupe le
poisson pour ensuite être vendu et tout
ce que vous voyez derrière moi mais en
fait ça part à la poubelle ou se
transformer en farine animale alors que
dedans et encore beaucoup de restes qui
sont propres à la consommation ici ça
représente jusqu'à 10 tonnes de poissons
par jour
tout ça c'est du bon poisson
dans les 50% qui restent il y a encore
une partie qui est jetée parce qu'il
respecte pas les standards de poids de
la restauration et de la demande de
consommation
minimum en vente histoire 10g le dos
c'est une prestation qu'on fait pour
après ta bière bon du coup on est obligé
de faire de respecter les télécharge
undy sur les berlues vous récupérez il y
a beaucoup de parties qui sont pas
mangés par l'homme tu vois là on va dire
quand on fait des loups oui le full au
ventre on va dire quoi ça part à la
malheureusement la poubelle certaines
personnes qui veulent pas on va dire au
niveau de la queue au niveau de la tête
on va le mettre dans des poches et on va
vendre ça sur nos poireaux la pêche on
récupère à peu près entre une tonne à 2
tonnes par semaine ou quand c'est
destinée ou en farine forcément c'est
dévalorisé les prix sont fracassés par
deux par trois ou par 4 là il se
rapproche presque du prix d'un poisson
normal donc ça lui permet aussi lui
demain de mieux payer les bars à
pêcheurs le poisson qui récupère Karim
est ensuite vendu dans une dizaine de
points relais ici en Bretagne on y
trouve aussi des paniers de fruits et
des légumes qui ne respectent pas le
cahier des charges de la grande
distribution j'ai passé ma journée avec
Karim pour mesurer à quel point on jeter
des aliments plutôt que de les manger on
va partir en production je vais
t'emmener voir des des chevaux de choux
d'artichauts et autres
confiance le covid aidé les catastrophes
écologique ces dernières années nous
annoncer et c'est maintenant qu'il faut
appuyer fort
c'est toutes les mêmes elles sont toutes
de la même forme elles sont toutes du
même poids pourquoi ben c'est justement
on en revient dans les années 90 pour
réglementer les achats de marchandises
entre les producteurs et la grande
distribution c'est là qu'on a
standardisé les produits on a écrit le
fameux cahier des charges dans lequel on
a écrit le produit idéal qu'on aimerait
recevoir tous les jours donc on va
écrire sa taille son poids sa longueur
son diamètre et par exemple pour le
concombre on va même écrire son degré de
courbure qui va être de maximum 5%. à
chaque fois que ça rentre pas dans ce
cahier des charges c'est retoqué
c'est-à-dire qu'on le détruit j'ai
peut-être pas fait de grandes études
mais pourquoi cette tomate là elle
serait vachement mieux que celle-là j'ai
toujours du mal à comprendre donc ça
c'est tous les produits anti gaspiques
qu'on vend dans notre supérette
contrairement aux tomates à l'heure où
tout est bien calibré tout fait bien la
bonne taille tout fait bien la bonne
couleur et ben là regarde tu as des
tailles de complètement différent ça
c'est du bio et ça ils en jette 10 à 15
tonnes tous les jours quand tu vois la
qualité de la carotte c'est tout juste
un scandale de pouvoir jeter ça chaque
jour nous ici on fabrique 4000 paniers
soit des paniers de légumes normaux ni
conventionnel soit des paniers de
légumes bio et on en est déjà un million
de paniers
en bio tu vois c'est super diversifié tu
as l'oignon bio de la pomme de terre bio
de la carotte bio du radis bio et du
choubiot donc voilà ce qu'on propose
pour un peu moins de 7 euros alors quand
on se producteur il donne ça aux vaches
il touche rien il n'y a rien et à ce
jour chez nous il gagne plusieurs
centimes d'euros au kilo ça varie selon
les produits ça varie selon la quantité
qu'on a à prier
avec la crise mondiale en ce moment et
de notre côté ici que tout le monde
d'avoir accès le fruit de légumes parce
que il y en a plein qui peut pas acheter
ça si cette idée de redonner une
nouvelle vie à tous les produits
alimentaires avec des prix bien étudiés
pas cher par rapport à tout ce qui se
passe tout le monde sera gagné
donc tu vois on est en train de préparer
des palettes donc tu vois même dans le
légume on a des biscuits souvent ces
gâteaux ils sont refusés tu vois parce
que pareil dans l'épicerie aussi des
cahiers des charges et ben la plupart
des enseignes des fois ils refusent
parce que le trait il est pas droit tu
vois c'est vachement embêtant j'ai
travaillé presque 25 ans dans la grande
distrie Intermarché continent aux champs
et Casino j'ai souvent été patrons des
achats fruits et des légumes c'est pour
ça que je ne jette la pierre à personne
parce que j'ai été de l'autre côté de la
barrière à l'époque quand on a écrit les
cahiers des charges mais je pense que je
cherche surtout une paix avec moi-même
tu sais que je travaille dans la grande
literie
comme un gamine allait à l'école je
disais toujours tu dis pas ce que fait
papa parce que j'étais le méchant pour
ceux qui travaillent en grande
difficulté le méchant
ben là je vois j'aimerais bien juste que
ma fille elle soit fière de moi je
t'emmène dans le Intermarché de Meillac
et dans la galerie marchande il y a un
petit commerce qui est devenu point
relais chez nous non depuis presque un
an à ce jour on est dans présent dans
les cinq départements bretons on a 60
points relais par exemple ici c'est
combien de paniers de légumes qui
partent en moyenne chaque jour on a deux
livraisons hebdomadaires je crois qu'au
mieux des semaines on a fait dans les
250 paniers peut-être
j'ai acheté voilà un panier fruits fruit
du soleil donc pourquoi 7 euros pour peu
près 4 kg je vais le voir je pense ils
sont tout à fait mangeables comestibles
en fait tels qui sont là donc moi je
vais je vais partir là-dessus on va voir
mais c'est sûr que l'économiquement
c'est vachement intéressant merci
j'ai toujours on vient un truc de dingue
c'est un rêve éveillé jamais ou sinon on
aurait été super prétentieux de dire que
on espérait une telle un tel engouement
de la part des consommateurs et une
telle réussite le projet à la prochaine
rentrée c'est d'ouvrir 1000 supérettes
anti-gaspi je vous rappelle on a démarré
il y a 12 mois 12 15 mois on avait zéro
salarié j'étais le seul salarié à ce
jour on est déjà à plus de 60 salariés
ça montre aussi qu'il y a il peut y
avoir un business de l'antigafi ouais il
peut y avoir un business dans l'anti
gaspille alors j'aime pas le terme
business parce que tout de suite les
gens disent il fait plein de pognon
machin etc c'est toujours souvent
péjoratif mais oui on peut entreprendre
dans l'anti-gaffie et oui on peut
changer les choses
en devenant membre
anti-gaspi en tout cas il est urgent de
se bouger pour pour devenir acteur on
peut plus regarder les trains passés et
puis ben quand on est en Bretagne on a
un devoir de le d'être les PREMIERS et
puis de faire bien les choses parce
qu'on est les plus gros producteurs donc
on est les plus gros gaspilleurs donc
c'est un autre prendre notre destin en
main